The second bonus question was what is the smallest angle α where the cannonball
makes it over the iceberg and can still hit the enemy ship?
Now this is different than the first question because in this question,
the cannonball just has to make it over the iceberg.
It doesn't necessarily have to curve down and hit the enemy ship, but in this question
the cannonball has to make it both over the iceberg and still hit the enemy ship.
So tell me what's the smallest angle is where this is actually possible.
Now, this question is really quite difficult, so don't feel bad if you can't get it
and please free to discuss it in the forums and keep in mind this isn't for credit--
so just have fun with this problem.